all right so let's first start off
gentleman with stripper bow is all to
talk is it true that you blew you blew
out $500,000 in that one night was that
was real money real money real cash yes
sir no cap will we see a stripper boy
another song be a part of the new movie
the card he's gonna be in because she
has clearly been styling and showing off
her her new life is diamond hold it down
you can't get you out of juice an artist
I don't know what you could expect you
got a seat way to see ya
y'all just won an award what did you
just win best group best group again
best group yes sir
all right you shot strippable during the
Super Bowl how did you keep a cap on
that for so long you know just being a
great label a great team a great group
we got a lot of guys performing tonight
from our label and we just wanted to
enjoy a night in the town and bring all
the money to Atlanta and bring all the
ladies to a line and just have fun
that's what we do yes if they had a
Super Bowl in the Super Bowl in Atlanta
we want a shower I was picking uh had a
stripper both just had a big birthday
party by the white could you have acted
a little more excited when you walked in
the door and I really thought I was
going somewhere I was really surprised
thought of something else yeah I thought
I was going to a hearse so yeah I mean
so much
enjoy it oh yeah I mean it's all good
you're performing tonight with cardi
right how is she doing and what is going
to happen because we know there have
been the legal issues as this came down
the greatest performance we're great
show anything and we finna rock stage
gonna be a beautiful thing you did will
it be clout y'all got performing for
show that's all I'm getting out there
and but really issue is everything gonna
be okay with the indictments and all
that somehow we will it be handled y'all
got it under control all right